what is going on everybody welcome to
part four or ltk with python for natural
language processing tutorial video in
this video we're actually talking about
something I think is really cool and
exciting and that's part of speech
tagging so up to this point we've talked
about pre-processing and stuff in and
part of speech tagging is pre-processing
but the other stuff was kind of yeah
this is cool there at least to me I hope
it is to you too so we're gonna be doing
part of speech tagging it means just
what it sounds it's labeling the part of
speech to every single word in whatever
you're feeding so usually it's in a
sentence but you might feed in whole
paragraphs if you want in so first of
all we're importing on CK then we're
going to go from NLT KDOT corpus
lovey-lovey corpus we're going to import
state Union so these are State of the
Union addresses by various presidents
over the last like 60 years or something
actually now that's probably more like
70 years anyways unless DK is it yes
good and then from lck tokenize import
and we'll use a different tokenizer
throw you guys for a loop we're gonna
use the Pumped sentence tokenizer so the
punx that gets it okay is be the punked
sentence tokenizer is a sort of
unspecial II not sort of it is it's an
unsupervised machine learning sentence
tokenizer
learning tokenizer you can train it if
you want it's comes pre trained but you
can retrain it on other stuff if you so
chose we'll just price use the default
one but I don't know I'll show you guys
probably how to train it so maybe it
won't and that's good enough for now
now we're going to need to pull in
actually we'll just keep on CK because
we're will do an else you got POS tag so
now what we want to do is let's get the
sample text and this will be state
underscore you
and then dot raw so we're gonna grab the
raw text for what text we want 2006 from
G W Bush dot txt that will be fun
now we're gonna say the custom sent
tokenizer so this is how you would go
about making your Punk sentence sentence
tokenizer you're very very own so that
will be equal to pumped sentence
tokenizer and we're gonna kind of do
something depression normally always do
but this will be fine custom sentence
Hogan Iser is the point second sent home
I guess I can't I can't say this Punk'd
sentence tokenizer on sample text
especially your training the Punk'd
sentence tokenizer on that text you can
bring through a different text
let's see stay the Union that should
occur every year so there should be
trained text 2005 there we go will be
legit about this so a custom sent
tokenizer punked sentence tokenizer
train text now we're gonna say
tokenized equals let's say tokenized
equals and that will be the custom sent
tokenizer dots tokenize of sample text
okay now let's go ahead and start using
some functions it's a fun process
concepts okay so we're gonna try accept
exception as be here and for now we'll
just print out string e so what we're
gonna try is we're gonna say for I in
tokenized this is for each little
element and then tokenized we're gonna
say words v equals l TK dot word
underscore two tokenize and we'll do i
so those would be the words and then
tags now is the following and let's see
K dot POS on our score tag and that will
be words okay so now for I then let's go
ahead and print tagged that should do
for hold on everybody settle down
this is the whole state of the Union so
we might not want to do area before I
and tokenized this will be a sentence so
let's just do
and this would be fine let's do it full
steam ahead
this might be way too big yeah that's
okay
oh we're not processing the content
let's let's call this function first
fine now full steam ahead everybody Oh
how long did george w bush yeah pond for
the state there we go okay we made it
all the way to the bottom awesome
applause okay so let's just I don't know
you can go wherever you want let's go to
the top so everybody can follow along so
president george w bush gets that these
are nouns before this is just too much
courageous JJ so actually that'd be a
good time to talk about what these
little meanings are okay so I'm looking
at him I'm like yeah that makes sense
y'all probably looking at these words
like what knocking so when you do this
part of speech tagging it will take and
create tuples of the word and then the
part of speech and instead of writing
them all out I'm just gonna go and copy
and paste them for you guys this over
here make some space and paste okay
these are your part of speech tags so si
si coordinating conjunction and then
like nnp is a proper noun and then
you've got you know verbs so vb v b DS
past tense Beauvoir the only one that's
weird i think is our yeah
our is adverbs so when you see that you
might not like in your head like when i
see these like PR p obviously actually i
always say that's a preposition but the
i n is our preposition so no it's good
idea to have this around because you can
quickly confuse yourself just dude so
that's it so we can come back over to
our output here so now you can see okay
now yeah and then fellow citizens today
courageous blah blah blah so what's
courageous for example JJ adjective okay
so those a success good
served let's see verb good good America
good got that so anyway you can go
through and look at all of them but for
the most part this actual part of speech
tagging is like perfect
it is nice it's going to mess up from
time to time especially unlike I think
of some good examples of when it messes
up definitely on some nouns like a lot
of times it's not gonna recognize nouns
especially if you're reading like
Twitter so eventually we may or may not
use Twitter as a dataset I'm
contemplating using like streams from
Twitter and you'll find that a lot of
people do not capitalize their persons
okay so a lot of times they'll have a
person's name but it's under lowercase
and an LT K is like what is this so that
can be kind of a problem sometimes over
the most part it's pretty darn good
so that's part of speech tagging pretty
simple again most of what we did before
we even got to part of speech tagging
was just getting some data and getting
some example sentences plus I want to
show you the Punk'd sentence tokenizer
look at me singing and also loading in
corpora like this standing Union Ron
George W Bush again we'll be talking
more about coop Rose very soon because
this is probably one of the biggest
things that like I think probably most
people that have used I don't see K
don't actually like going look and see
what they have in their corpora because
it's actually our corpus it's actually a
lot of really good stuff in there a lot
of golden nuggets so to speak so anyways
that's it for part speech tagging it's
really quite simple really boils down to
after you've split by word you can pass
through the antique a part of speech
tagging now now I will show it to you
yet when we get to chunking I'll show
you how you can display everything
that's really pretty so anyways that's
it for part of speech tagging if you
have any questions or comments concerns
whatever please feel free to leave them
below otherwise as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support of
subscriptions and until next time